all right and we are live the last word
with Laura Cognito Eddie Vance's fresh
at the campfire Friday morning since we
got some special guests in the building
what's going on here feel special today
uh we definitely got a special lady
coming from across the pond and we're
gonna jump right in and bring her into
this thing the only way we would know
how at the last word with a grandiose
intro so here we go
welcome to the last word episode 116.
it's a great Friday morning and we have
an amazing lady joining us so grab your
seat around the campfire let's do this
I'd like to introduce a lady who works
her tail off non-stop so much that
instead of sleep she has sups running
through her veins to keep her going she
has a wide variety of gaming background
titles including Halo The Witcher but
still is a soft spot for Tomb Raider and
why wouldn't she it's another woman
kicking butt she's a badass mom who
could School most of us on raid content
while still taking care of her daughter
and even cleared a crown of Sorrow on
day one so let's welcome another great
member of the last rites and the Ascend
stream team producer of both Saturday
night warm-up and the guardian Royale
with James work someone who knows the
best rate is King's fall a Die Hard
Hunter and plenty of space in her
backpack robotic Katie how are you doing
this morning
I'm doing amazing that was that was like
I was very honored there I'm gonna need
you right to record that and I'm gonna
do that at the start of every stream
that was amazing thank you so much
welcoming you are welcome how are you
doing this morning welcome for all the
way from across the pond in Scotland
love the accent how you feeling
I'm feeling good I'm feeling good this
is uh it's earlier for you guys than it
is for me it's two o'clock in the
afternoon for me so it's not too bad
um thank you so much for inviting me on
uh this is really exciting so pleasure
oh it's it's our pleasure I feel like
I'm actually just more returning the
favor after being a part of joining the
Saturday night warm up and squeaked into
the Royale even though uh I feel like
the the meal question I gotta I got a
bit of a shaft there from Gixxer but you
know yeah yeah
we're gonna talk about that photo
you got the better food you're out yeah
yeah it's like no it's like I think
there was uh yeah it's like they they're
friends there I see how that's your
class well I gotta speak to a Titan we
don't uh
every time the producer but never wins
the blumen show I'm like okay that's
fine
at some point you need to win one of
these things and just have him set in
the background yeah yeah pretty much
just like take away
to be fair we're looking at um we're
looking at changing things a little bit
but nothing's set in stone so I wouldn't
want to go too much into it but the um
the Saturday night uh warm up and then
also Garden Royale was certainly it was
James's brainchild and it came to me and
he was like hey this is what we want
this is what I want to do
um do you want to help me and I'm like
huh
you've got so many people that we you
know
like a lot larger in the community but
to be fair a lot of people are large in
the community have their own stuff going
on so like it was it was a huge honor
and I love that um and it was an
absolute pleasure to have you on a bonus
even though that we're in last nights
like we haven't really um crossed paths
too much which is an error on my part as
well I'm just as bad as anybody on that
stuff so you are fine
well I'm working on doing this that the
other all of a sudden oh okay we have no
time yeah yeah
get into some questions with Addie see
what's going on so what yeah let's talk
about just your journey you know in the
beginning you know we obviously we all
here at the campfire have this passion
for this game of ours this this Destiny
thing so uh let's start there as far as
like your passion for Destiny and just
what got you into content creation
so
um
I was uh I just had my daughter and
everything and
um I
my daughter's father had basically given
me the game and he was hey this looked
kind of cool you know you want to play
it so I actually came into Destiny
around about rise of iron time so I was
spoiled for Content you know because I
had all of it yeah
yeah so I started playing a little bit I
got to know a few people
um I have the first time I actually
started playing with people like in an X
because I started on Xbox and an Xbox
party is we cleared prison of Elders on
this person was just like hey you know
you played really well
um do you want to join us we're going to
run it again I'm like yeah sure so we
jumped in a voice chat
um
instead of typically when you used to
jump in a voice chat and you started
talking oh my God it's a girl I have
none of that I have none of that without
the um that group and it was great
awesome just kind of spend time gaming
and stuff and then
um I really
so I suffered from postnatal depression
and Destiny was a really good way to
I suppose kind of not not hide from it
but like
um with the postnatal depression that I
had it was very very difficult for me to
leave the house
um I had
um
I had a lot of friends and I kind of
lost contact with over the years and
then especially after I had Willow
um she's now four
um it's it was very very difficult for
me to
um go outside and be able to meet people
because it was just
anxious terrified feeling and so
gaming became my uh became the way that
I socialize
um destiny 2 was the second game I've
ever pre-ordered the first one was
Borderlands
yeah they gonna like that they all
definitely slow mo I see you swallowing
but yeah
I forgot to say I'm a huge huge fan of
board Lawns Borderlands 2 will always be
my favorite game Maya is the one that's
in my heart
um
but
um so I've gotten a Destiny 2 on the
Xbox and I was playing it I was having
fun and then I was in a relationship and
we had talked about
um multi-streaming so basically it would
be me and him on one Channel streaming
together and everything like that
however he wasn't a huge fan of he
wasn't the biggest fan of Destiny and
then
[Music]
um
after that he actually found like a
night job so I ended up taking
um
I ended up just you know continuing on
on my channel
um
it just kind of continued from there so
I've been doing this for
two and a half years now wow very cool
it's been amazing it's been slow and
steady and everything that I kind of
wanted you know
kind of laid that Foundation of fun and
positivity and just gaming and then
um
so I became quite
I got into quite a few communities on
Twitch and one of them was James work
um yeah I used to love the work yeah
yeah yeah and so
um I started on
uh
I was obviously still on Xbox and then I
moved over to a PC and I've got to tell
you I've really gone back to Xbox since
the frames
I switched and I haven't touched it yeah
one day that field of view the phrase
kind of nice ain't it
so I um
I started helping James with uh teaching
raid runs and stuff and since then
that's like I cut my teeth on Spire the
Stars
you cut them real hard there
so
so love it
yeah spire's up there and some of my
favorite reads can I can I call you when
it's time for me so I get the Catalyst
because I don't want to do that
I got you okay because I hate that but
all right so tell me I know we go we're
going off yesterday but why do you like
spiders so much I have to know this
um it's the
it's it's one of the few reads that
everybody has to Leviathan you can have
three people that know what the theory
yeah life and you can have three people
that know what you're doing and you've
got three people that can just sit and
have them in corner
um or like just sit and shoot some
arrows and stuff like that
you know Leviathan is more to me
Leviathan feels like a game show it's
not a raid
um I'll give you that I was like yeah
that's not right Leviathan feels like
callous American Ninja
I'll give you that I'll give you you are
I'll absolutely give you that so Spire
to me is
um
although it sadly followed the line that
Bungie started with you start with this
encounter hey this is teaching you how
to do this and then hey you're gonna do
this for the it was I think it was the
first raid in Destiny 2 that I actually
really properly did that like you your
first encounter is Inc is basically
um getting used to how the mechanics are
gonna work and then that was it more
green yeah
um but for me I think Spire Andrew is
where everybody has to be on the ball
and has that is true you know you have
to have four people you you cannot three
man not raid you can three man all the
way up to the bottom all the way up to
the first encounter but you can't do it
you have to have four people on the
plates you have to have two people that
know what they're doing all that kind of
stuff you know
um so for me uh
Spire was at the time when Spyro came
out Spire was probably the most
difficult breed to do yeah oh yeah
absolutely especially with teaching so
um and a lot of people say that it's
really buggy and stuff and yeah there
can be some bugs but sometimes it is
actually down to people just not
understanding how the mechanics works
I feel like James said the same thing
he's like oh it's not it's not buggy
I'll just show you how to do it and I
was just like laughing on the inside
shots yeah there is there is bugs don't
get me wrong like you know I've seen the
bugs and I've experienced them but I
don't think it's as buggy as some people
people make it to see like people will
say and when they're doing Prestige oh I
haven't seen them armed I haven't seen
them armed the thing what you've got to
remember is that Spire the stars as well
as eater or not so
um
that changes when you're in a Prestige
Spiro the message is intentionally don't
come up right you have to trust in your
your team and your fire team to to see
that it's actually armed and everything
like that
um
but I I love that I'm a platformer I
love Platformers
and that's why I love King's Falls so
much you're smiling right now yeah oh my
God over here you guys gush over this
Ray continue
the mechanics and the the the the the
platforming and everything was huge for
me because Kings for like so I I
encounter crota first
um with a team and quote I was I I
thoroughly enjoyed I can understand why
people view it as like a strike it's not
really a raid but as as someone who wow
um but for someone who is
Destiny brought something entirely new
to me I had never encountered reading
I've never encountered six people
working together for and that's
something that a lot of people
I still don't experience that I've never
played Destiny and I read quite a lot of
the destiny population have never done a
raid talk about it
so low and it's a shame because it's
some of the best content and like you
said that's literally what made me stay
with the game once I once I experienced
it it was it was Game changing to me I
had never done anything like that on
Console so again like you said the six
people mechanics playing together
trusting your teammates learning stuff
all those things it's a bonding
experience when you complete it so I
completely completely agree with you
mm-hmm cool
Spire is up there for one of those raids
because it does have mechanics and it
has the movement and the the platforming
section is one of my favorites it really
really is so so yeah
oh go ahead and go ahead no no go ahead
go ahead I was gonna ask you keep saying
platforms I just want to know like what
Platformers did you like grow up on
stuff like that where where'd the
platforming love come from
so I say platforming because that's what
it it is but I think for me my love of
exploding and jumping and everything
comes from Tomb Raider because it's Tomb
Raider you went everywhere you could
climb you could jump you'd like
two major really fostered my love for
puzzles in games for critical thinking
for like okay if I do this this is gonna
happen and sometimes Tomb Raider was
really obvious and other times it really
wasn't the Angel of Darkness had me
tilted for like three months because I
couldn't figure out the da Vinci puzzle
um
but
um so with Tomb Raider and then
um that kind of like exploration
um puzzle fight puzzle solving and just
the movement kind of like really
fostered my love for that so like when
when I'm in a raid and I'm like oh I
have to do jumping and it's not linear
yeah that's I hate I hate having to like
gos gos is probably one of my least
favorite rates it's very pretty it is
good this is spicy
visually it's wonderful it really is
mechanically
it's boring you don't like the conga
line you don't want to get your
attention
[Music]
no I'm just I honestly I think at this
stage I'm just
I'm just tired of having to okay to be
fair the hard people's fight the actual
fight where you kill the Harvey boss is
great I like that yeah right that's
that's cool because it's moving it's a
moving box
I am sick of standing on one place oh
okay got it I did melting gotcha okay
it's it's gotten to the stage now bro
this is like if we had uh a raid boss
that's like the prophecy dungeon boss I
was just that came to my mind because I
was like she got the love prophecy now
yeah I get it now
it satisfies Your platforming Love with
the Hops
I got you ready I got you closely the
constant moving and everything is super
it's it adds an extra layer instead of
just standing in a well or standing in a
bubble and you know Melody yes yeah yeah
like I I love it like I love the the
fact that
um
like so Riven okay careful already
careful go you talk about Last Wish
though careful full mechanics Riven boss
fight
is my favorite in this and don't worry I
got you I got you
don't get me wrong I was getting dark I
love like I love the fact that we can
feel so powerful that we can give her
manicure and we can just you know send
her away we literally I did that last
night like just melted the whole raid
with swords actually every boss swords
done every single boss you can do right
now swords is so powerful right now and
I love that I really do love that I do
swords is in a different instead of us
like we sort of have a little bit of a
risk factor to it right yeah I mean
because you have to be right there
absolutely I like that I don't I'm not a
big fan of sitting in the back in a well
and firing Izanagi or you know what I
mean
zero phage you know what yeah pick your
giant weapon
to be fair like that's what we'll use on
a garden boss we'll use xenophage
because right now we can't go near it
with like a shotgun or anything just
because we can't get that exactly
because it rises they made it float in
the air like they made it exactly
exactly if I could kill that thing with
swords are weird I'm gonna maybe attempt
at some point the uh The Temptations
hook I'm just trying to see if you can
have your target to death that'll be
fine
um but yeah so like Spire is probably up
there in one of my favorite raids
um it kind of goes so if we're just
talking D2 yeah it's Last Wish crown of
Sorrow
um
spire
eater gos
Geo wow yeah it's a little it's a little
U.S
um
and then Leviathan and then no no no
then sotp the scourge yeah
so although the boss fight is
interesting The Scourge yes the reason I
hate that raid so much is because I
spend 18 hours in it to Manning it so
my my um
my hatred of Scrooge is well known
says lies we all know Addy's favorite
colors
but yeah like I think to me as well like
Spa uh sltp wasn't that it wasn't
engaging to me like I get it there was
mechanics and there was movement and
stuff like that but I I to me
so I thrive in chaotic
environments so phase two crown of
Sorrow gotcha is the bread is like the
butter to my bread
I'm gonna assume churrochi Last Wish
also kind of the movement and the all
the chaos going and getting on the place
everybody should go down and move you
know again again that kind of stuff yeah
I love that kind of stuff the only thing
that I don't like about it so I have a
bit of a hate love relationship with
shiruchi I love the encounter I hate it
because I had to run it so often for
which witch challenge oh there you go
we accidentally managed to do uh a witch
witch Challenge on a Petra run because
you were that careful
cheers so the the problem with shirochi
is the the laser that she fires that you
have to avoid being hit by if I hit to
tether a wall or anything that you
produce as a guardian that counts
against you oh wow so that's what
um I think that's why I just like that
part because
you know you guys got like special rules
going on like yeah she's got a very
specific hatreds of this one yeah
section facet of this encounter turned
sideways on its head
yeah pretty much like there's there's
some encounters that I just I just don't
like I'm not fair enough
I think probably one of my like if I was
to look at Leviathan for example I think
one of my favorite fights would have to
be Carlos himself yes I love the the
plate to play and yeah yeah
the void room is really really good
um and that's movement and you have to
trust in your teammates because cross
shooting those sounds man otherwise
you're booped and you're gone oh yeah
um
and let me tell you I've spent some
hours in a prestigious Leviathan
yeah it's not fun when you don't got the
good chemistry and the good
synchronization with a team yeah but
like
every like in every individual raid can
be looked at and there is positives and
there's negatives towards I know a lot
of people hate crime and I understand it
because the first encounter takes two
notations too long it's yeah I don't
understand why it took so long but
the rest of the raids like the the whole
the entire time you spend in the boss
room I love it because it's just a
chaotic energy it's just like you have
to run into Mexico you know what I mean
and it's got a jumping like literally
jump shoot jump shoot jump shoot just to
get there so again yeah speaking right
to you platforming yeah yeah it makes
sense you got some questions for Audi uh
yeah so I mean obviously you're huge in
the PVE like world and Carries and stuff
like that but also a fan of the world of
Gambit so two questions one
um
just kind of the status of Gambit right
now because I know when Gambit started
like when they did like the the kind of
initial tournament that was very set
Loadout stuff like that versus how we
are now
where do you think like just Gambit is
currently in a status and then the
second question for you since you
probably have a good opinion on it where
do you think it's going to end up with
Beyond light when it kind of sinks down
into one mode
um
right now I think
Gambit's in a bad place
as someone who is like you know I am a
huge fan of Gambit clearly you know what
I mean but
I played a lot of it season of The
Drifter I took part in the UK tournament
that was run
um we nearly got to the finals very very
cool I feel like we had Zoe on who was
in that too yep there's only one I
believe yeah yeah I did yeah and she did
um
but
Gambit right now is in a really bad
place with the amount of
overpowered weapons we have
um you can start a saw with with say
Normie Gambit but the two Vines you can
well three runs technically
um
you can start a boss smell without even
having to kill the the envoys because
you've got oppressive darkness and
you've got swords yes and a bubble and
that boss is melted within like
10 seconds oh yeah I've seen him go down
so fast this week yeah yeah it's crazy
um
the other problem is obviously invading
invading is yes
so it's very highly debated right but I
think the personally invading is an
integral part to Gambit if you took away
invading then it's just it's a race to
see who can kill the boss first right
right absolutely you know
um which is interesting like I could I
would definitely like to try
um Gambit just one you know
Boss Rush race you know what I mean that
kind of thing right but I think invading
adds that extra element that involves
the PVP player yes I think a lot of
people seem to forget that you know
Gamba is a pvep so that more PVP players
can get involved and they can actually
feel like they're doing what they think
is their skill set which is going and
invading and taking care of you know
um basically hampering the other teams
sabotaging the other team
um
going down but Prime came out and with
the armor sets the armor sets are
amazing
um but they need tuned they really do
um
unfortunately the Sentry set in the
collector set are wildly underwhelming
comparatively compared to like Invader
and Reaper Reaper is is very very
powerful but I think personally it's
balanced I don't think there's anything
overpowered with Reaper
um you know you get the added bonus to
to damage when you hit a large Target
and everything like that the Invader set
definitely needs tuned as you know you
already get an overshield when you go
over adding an extra layer of protection
is is very difficult to overcome and
that's why personally I feel that's why
like xenophage like Hammerhead Reigns
Supreme over so long for so long
all of these
um
all of the weapons that we start to
complain about
um the people use for invading or they
use to counter Invaders is because
I think it's born I I see it as it's
been born because of Gambit Prime and
how powerful
um
or Justin okay how how powerful Invaders
can be they also need to I don't think
the Invaders now I was an Invader Main
that's what I did that was that was my
role whenever we played Gambit
um I think that they need to definitely
tune down the um the overshield and they
definitely need to take down the wall
hacks I think yeah I think that honestly
I think they should they should tune it
so you get a pulse when you start when
so when you when you get trying when you
go through the portal and you get you
get a pulse just they're here and then
it disappears for like 15 seconds okay
and then boom Another pulse and then
that's it that's the only indications
you have of where they are so you
actually have to go hunting to go hunt
Okay so so just to cut that to cut you
out so basically what you're saying is
you don't want the Invader to always
have the wall hack to know exactly where
they are you want that pulse then it
goes blank and they literally have to
hunt for the Guardians so they don't
just can be like okay I see we going
with it
go ahead oh is it gonna say the big
thing about that is you can't ever flank
an Invader I mean unless you truly
teleport behind them on the couple maps
that you can do that if they have that
like giant wide field of view especially
on like PC for like what's coming out of
my picture just like the forest one on
edz in that corner when they start by
the beach you can see everything and
they know like are you going around are
you going through the middle like they
know where you're coming from so it's
like just waiting on you it would be
nice just to have an idea of be like oh
I think they were coming this way but
you Juke around the building and maybe
catch them from the side they wouldn't
see it as much yeah I totally
go ahead
sorry I don't mean to cut you off I'm
just so that's my idea my idea for
um
my idea for the century set yes
what do you want what we doing
I wanted to kind of be the flip side of
Invader so when an Invader Cuts so the
century is meant to take care of lockers
and they Mark Invaders now the only Mark
Invaders when they actually hit them I
think that they should be able to mark
Invaders if they have a line of sight
I like that okay okay it's almost like a
ping but what I also think that Sentry
should have a good the problem right now
right is if you play an awful lot of gun
but you'll start to recognize where
they're going to spawn the spawn points
are obvious however if they end up
adding more maps at the end of uh with
Beyond light right
um I think
um centuries should be able to just get
a a pulse as well okay so like an
indication I don't maybe
[Music]
um
I don't think the century should have
the the secondary pulse okay
um
because one pulse should be enough to
tell your team if you're running stacked
right tell your team right okay hey boom
over there and then that's it yeah
um and then if you end up seeing them
it's marked and you can you know it the
mark would last maybe five SEC five
seconds six seconds or something it
wouldn't be the problem is if you that I
find is that if you have something
that's
um
continuous the entire time
it's kind of game breaking which is why
Invaders are so bloody powerful yeah you
know what I mean I know everybody yet
you see the number of remotes on the
head they know who the target like The
Invader got the advantage when it comes
and the overshield they got the
advantage they literally teleport over
in the bank shuts yes yes so that's uh
that's another the only I think it only
locks the bank when you have the full
Invader set yeah correct me if I'm wrong
no I think that sounds right yeah yeah
and you're able obviously to join the
moats and stuff I think that um
when they condense it down what I would
like to see is one round because lights
make me over and you're trying to do
your three or four thousand matches
that's where time goes because you don't
want to be doing potentially three
rounds per Gambit match to get your
powerful done right um or your Pinnacle
part of me
um
I want to see it condensed down the salt
one Mark at not one month but like one
round yep
um
I want the armor sets to still be in
there because the armor sets are are so
wonderful it's such a brilliant idea
they look better though okay they look
better because
we get some aesthetically pleasing
gambits because I am not I I feel like
he he looks like a hobo I don't like my
warlock
at all at all
innovator one but the whole life's
terrible
yeah the Invader said
they're nice the hunter I think
it's just a giant sheet of decoration
that Bungie has fun with every time as
opposed to here's a shoulder pad you
can't see through and then warlocks over
here just wearing a dress so you're
wearing a dress with the snake um
with your little arm bracelet be like
hold on I gotta cut off circulation in
my arm I gotta make it by myself
[Laughter]
what I would like to see is then
get rid of Reckoning we don't need
Reckoning we really don't need it I
think that it was very
ambitious to think that we would enjoy
going to a separate game mode to earn
things for a different game mode
um agreed
or they could have easily put on
secondary perks on the Gamba armor like
the the stuff you get from Reckoning to
be able to protect you better in
Reckoning that was the worst part yeah
you earn stuff for in a PBE activity for
the pvep mix but it didn't even help you
in what you earned it in so as you got
better in there that didn't get that's a
whole in-game issue right now but that's
still oh yeah yeah I would think
recordings got to go also from uh from a
lower standpoint now we've kind of moved
on Prophecy you know I I wouldn't I
would assume that they're not going to
tie those two anymore when they decide
on this one Gambit mode and move forward
hopefully hopefully I mean from a lower
standpoint
um it's going to be interesting
so
the Reckoning was basically to test us
and everything like that now
um especially with how they should
um
how the the nine well how the MS City
and how the nine work with The Drifter
um obviously it's all coming to point
now you know the the sword The Hourglass
and the
sword hourglass and there was something
else and I can't remember what it was
but obviously it
um
it all ties together with EXO stranger
and
with Iris and with The Drifter
um but that's like that's a different
tangent I could talk about lore all day
I was enjoying that too don't worry feel
free to fall down those rabbit holes at
any time
in Gambit like yeah give us challenges
to do I know people hate bounties don't
give us bounties tie it to triumphs
instead so it's you have to earn it I
don't want so
spicy
it should not
this is a looter shooter Grind game you
should not have to be you shouldn't uh
you already there
you might as well
commit commit to it right there just
don't whine that you can't get something
because you haven't put the time into it
you know it's like it's like you don't
you don't want the season pass to just
hand you an exotic when you log in
what honestly no I think that I hate
that crap too trust me I hate that we
fully support you I'm pretty sure
that no that's kind of one of those
things for me that's bugged me since
they started the season passes you log
in and you're giving an Exotica I'm like
you're just devaluing Exotics every
single time you do that it really does
feel good Exotics aren't exotic anymore
no
what it what is what is more exotic is
the pursuit weapons yeah we had like
revoker on mountaintop and recluse all
of those kind of weapons were more
exotic than the Exotics that we have
because they are however not
to sponge you too much they are doing
better ruinous Effigy has got to be one
of the best Exotics so I have used in
Destiny 2. so cool
horde and sorrow sheep
is amazing yeah yeah all the ground yeah
that type of stuff is great like and the
way they if they can again continue to
like if they have like Trinity ghoul
well I forget what I was I was just
running oh yeah I was doing just public
events and it was just all over edz and
you just have the the Fallen uh glimmer
public event it's just all the drop
ships I'm just like and just chaining
lightning constantly I'm like this is so
much fun
yeah there's there's a lot that don't
and I think the other piece is too now
we've had when you get into the higher
activities I say this probably every
time so sorry everybody but you can
start counting the episodes that's in
there uh the fact that Exotics are
you're pushed away from them in so many
high level activities with the Champions
especially if you need to do one
overload and one other and unless you're
gonna go with like everybody's gonna use
Ariana's vowel and everybody like
there's only certain ones you're pushed
away from so many others I'd like to see
again the variety there as well I mean
they are trying to fix it they are
they're and I think they're toying with
fixing that now because obviously we've
got the Unstoppable pulse mod for us
armor yeah that's the first time and I
was like the first creep into that zone
that we we're talking about that needs
to happen I agree I think they are they
are starting to I think they are
starting to play with that because it's
gonna enable us to be able to use these
Exotics
um because I mean let's be real how how
often
have we said or do you have as an Aggies
on oh if I gonna zanagis are you going
to run Ariana's
um Anarchy everything like that but like
for me personally
my Loadout for Grand Masters right now
is izanagi's
um a pulse rifle okay
um and the sword okay one question you
got your distances covered you got is it
now you're long no you got okay okay I
see what you're doing cool and then with
the
with the armor I'm mostly
um
as a hunt remain I never take off Dragon
Shadow I use Dragon Shadows Dragon
Shadow and PVE and PVP because that
exotic is hugely undervalued right now
and I've been shouting about it for like
the past eight months
recently there is a video
like for the people who don't know
remind them what dragon Shadow does for
the ones
so base what it does is when you dodge
you get granted riff male or
yeah and what that does is it reloads
every single one of your weapons it
doesn't matter if you've got it equipped
or not um it gives you Max handling it
basically gives every gun snapshot and
also
it gives you 100 Mobility
if if so it adds an extra five tiers in
this eight seconds it adds an extra five
tiers of Mobility
so if say you're looking at PVP
um and you're you want to be you know
for me dragon shadow makes sense to me
because uh it loads my weapons and it
gets me I can use the the bottom Dodge
the gamblers Dodge yes and it can get me
out of encounters that I probably won't
win
um so it
reloads all of the weapons and then
um I can have my if I have my Mobility
50 or more it will give me my Dodge back
in a total of nine seconds wow
that's powerful so you can you can
constantly live in race metal and it's
really really really good in PVE because
say you're trying to
um
you're trying to like in a Grandmaster
if you're up against something and
goodness it's just put up a shield my
Ariana isn't reloaded because you know
go ahead and hold them down that's
probably my phone has not been reloaded
anymore because I've got the blooming
um The Catalyst now which is all okay
now I see it canvas is nice but like say
something
um
I'm trying to fight something and my
weapon's not reloaded I dodge and as
soon as it because
it adds the handling and then it has the
snapshot I can then instantly start to
to counter it
um it's just it's a very very powerful
idea oh yeah passive exotic I suppose
because it doesn't doesn't change
anything like stompies I know a lot of
people are a fan of stompies I genuinely
don't understand why because I tend to
over jump things on stompies rather than
and the only I use stompies for one
thing and that's the whisper mission
the only time I use
but that's kind of one of those that
it's nice to have Exotics like that for
if you especially get yourself used to
it at all that are useful all the time I
can't stand the eight Exotics that are
you know upon getting to critical health
or if you're near dead or if you're dead
like or if it's just for your super for
like that one use like yeah if you get
to use your exotic and changes the way
you play like 80 of the time you
actually get to enjoy that a lot more
than when you cast your super you get an
overshield I'm calling you Eternal
Warrior for example calling out yeah
it's like stormcaller coat for a warlock
that's the same way like oh it's more
powerful when you get your super and I'm
like okay but then the rest of the 80 of
the time that I don't have this super
this is useless yeah like but yeah they
should be secondary functionality yeah I
completely agree continue I'm sorry
yeah
yeah so that's all I was basically
saying is like I completely agree like
those ones where if you dodged you're
handling and weapons are faster in
reloading as you said almost snapshot
and you get that every time you dodge
and you pair it up with mobility and
you're all of a sudden like running that
way the whole time you get to feel
badass like most of the time which is
cool as opposed to cool my super is
awesome and then I gotta wait five
minutes doesn't quite have the same ring
to it oh absolutely absolutely I wanted
to ask Audi real quick because I know we
went raid for a little bit stuff like
that and I know I saw E's face perk
during the king's fall mention so uh yes
as as his Audis right now so you know
listen I got no B for kids for us not my
number one but it's up there but I
wanted to ask you like okay Kings fall
specifically because I saw some stream
names some titles Audi he was like don't
at me King's fall
so now is the time I'm adding you
what's up with kids but get break it
down why you love it so much
King's full
um
okay to start off with I'm a huge lore
nerd I love lore I love reading the
stories I love getting fully immersed in
a world
um the lore Behind The Hive and the
taken uh
capturing captures like basically
captured me more than anything else in
this game and like any other any other
lore
um
and just uh
I think so obviously crota was okay it
was like honestly crew has probably got
one of the one of the best
one of the best opening to be fair
because let's be real
you're in The Labyrinth and you're
terrified because it's all dark and
crawler coming at you it's good cool
it's good good aesthetic yeah but King's
fall was the daddy and it was like
okay okay all right we're gonna
um
for me I think it was just the
difference in encounters and there was
there was an element of standing still
and shooting at the boss golgroth for
example you jumped in the pool you just
stood there and you just fired in his
stomach but
you know if he took if you know if he
fired at you for more than two seconds
you ever died that's it you know
um
I honestly
[Music]
um
I think that
Kings fall itself it it really touched
obviously on the platforming with the
the wall
um I wouldn't use the term I normally
use for that wall no you're fine
the uh phalic wall yes
um I think
that and then the boss fight itself it's
rare that you get
overwhelmed
by how large The Raid bosses yeah oh
yeah good point good point when I first
started that raid and oryx just kind of
rose up I was like
oh hi yeah there were no reaction videos
to that when people are like what just
like run it the other way and everything
but that was I totally agree because we
finally got and unfortunately we had
that and then you have something like
warmind where you totally did disservice
to like a worm God yeah like on the
other side but we got to see like a
taken you know by the lore top three
Hive you know entity basically and then
you get to see him Ascend and you're
just like holy dude and you just like
you have to beep it out because yeah you
know when his hand slams down and you're
just like looking at his hand and you're
like it's bigger than me like yeah it's
the scale they made in that whole room
was fantastic there be there may be
nothing below his pecs on the in that
room for his model he may just like move
around like this so there may be nothing
else but from there up looks fantastic
no you're absolutely right it's it's the
sheer sense of scale that you feel like
you are fighting a boss you are fighting
you know saying the hive King idiots I
have to admit he's definitely one of the
most imposing bosses I think they've
ever made I mean yeah I think that's why
I actually like Riven as well because I
miss that epic skills yeah like you know
what I'm saying I think that's what
that's a good point that's a good point
I I would agree with that yeah
I was just gonna say for me like the war
priest fight too is I like how it
escalated because the way it was like
you know the Big Flash and everybody had
to hide for a minute and then you're
like frantically cleaning stuff out
staying under the plates communicating
and everything the war priest fight I
know golgaroth is like some people hold
really high because you've got like the
room and the pools and everything but
the war priest fight no win win smooth
was cool but teaching people that at
first and not standing in the right
place and the lower priest fight was
always kind of cool as well and just
again it's like the it seemed to
escalate as you go like War priest was
decent size golgoroth was this ugly
mother and then you had the pair of
sisters like sisters they scream at you
and they're met and then just it went to
like level 12 and I was just like damn
so like I don't know
escalated well too and as you said the
lore crota dead son pissed off Dead
comes in Melts after like the lore
implication that was still some of my
favorite too hence why the witch Queen
is what I'm probably most excited about
as well oh oh yes I cannot wait to
finally face savathune it's gonna be
great and I think the other thing with
with especially so I see a lot of people
that complain about the the king soil
boss fights is it you have to detonate
those orbs or you know blah blah blah
blah the thing is there's a lot of
there's more interesting intricacy to
the boss fight itself anyway you know
that's just yeah sure that's how you do
damage to to oryx but there's a lot of
moving parts to it as well like you have
the designated Runner that's another
thing is the fact that you have
we have teams doing things it was me too
yeah you know like it's it's you have
teams doing things you got the three
people that jump on you've got the
people that stay in the middle and try
and keep their enemies away you've got
the person running up at the top and
then like trying to
be really fast and then there's the
night and then I like
the boss fight itself was really really
to me at the time it was really
intricate and there was a lot of there
was a lot going on and like I said
chaotic energy I love it makes sense
yeah I think
Kingsville I fell a little crueler to me
was a raid because it was the first
thing I experienced I had I didn't think
I did caught up before I did vlog
um
Vogue to me beautiful
I don't know say it I gotta hear this
one there it goes there it goes I think
it's overrated
oh she was doing so well she was doing
so loud
and it has been and it is Big
we respect all opinions even with the
wrong but it's okay it's okay now please
don't explain why we feel it's overrated
okay so don't get me wrong okay I am not
I am not diminished because obviously a
lot of people
look bad they love it because it was
their first read it was the first thing
they'd ever experience reading wise and
Destiny
um I'm being messy continue
stop being emotional please continue
yeah and I get that there's a lot of
nostalgia there's a lot of
frozen rose tinted glasses really when
you look back at Disney one as a whole
as a whole when you look back at D1
there's a lot of people that are like
um
oh Destiny one was so good blah blah
blah blah blah but then I still hear
from people that there was like nine
months of content drought oh how was
that how is that better than D2 now we
are although it's not a lot we're still
getting content dropping throughout the
year for people that are like don't get
Destiny was an amazing introduction to
the universe
but I think a lot of people like to to
really look back at the really good
things about Destiny one and not look at
the bad things I gotta stop you oh we
implying that Destiny 2 is the overall
better experience
no
um
if you take away year one of Destiny 2
then yes
okay so you have three years and three
years right now yeah the overall
Encompass like the three years first
three years how's that feel
so I can't really speak from what I've
what from what I know okay fine two
years and three years
[Laughter]
you played crota so you got to
experience that you got King's fall if
you spend enough time in there so you
got you know half of D1 versus uh D2
I think D2 is definitely better
spicy
oh I agree I agree though like the I I'm
D1 was something for console that had
never been done Bungie yeah Bungie went
through and made Halos one of the first
shooters for Xbox it was a special
moment because Halo in itself changed
the game for Shooters they're like you
can't do it in a console done like you
did Bungie once again made something
special for Shooters in a game with
raids and PVE and putting this world
together that people get like hooked
into and honestly like the way they've
taken everything from D1 that was a good
foundation but if you take away the rose
tint of living through that yeah year
one of D2 not the best I mean yeah it
was like the double primaries a lot of
bad decisions but you used to go like
forsaken was one of the best things that
has ever happened over the course of
this history of everything you had the
story with the two Destiny like the
dreaming City Surprise the fact that we
got the shattered Throne the scale of
the Last Wish dungeon apparently we
dabbing right now so
I love how the guest does it too and but
also you've got things like you know
we've now got exotic Catalyst for the
first time we've got mods that as the
game continues to evolve they're
learning and growing it and
like I I know right now we're gonna have
a drought for
three months because he got August of
you know Solstice of Heroes which some
people may burn through in a week if
you're crazy but it's You Know It's a
Grind we'll talk about it here in a
little bit because you know we got into
a tangent here of an hour but that's
fine we
a down month in the middle which I don't
expect a whole lot we're gonna finish
Travelers chosen but you know normal
timing aside like Beyond light honestly
is something I'm extremely excited for
because it feels like it has the weight
of another forsaken and again like the
king's fall expansion like King's fall
taken King expansion forsaken
and now we get another one but it's just
like the way it's continued to evolve
like d2's only like D2 year one is the
big giant asterisk in the corner of that
statement yeah we just conveniently
ignore him but no I'm not I'm not but I
would say in the overall thing we have
had we're on season 11.
we had you know expansion we had taken
King and then we had rise of iron we had
nine months we had like 10 months
basically
with an April update so
yeah just overall like the two packages
and the evolution of things that we've
learned yeah there was a giant like face
plant in the beginning but they picked
themselves up like clean themselves up
and and I think were ahead of where D1
got to personally yeah
um I think
um
I think the thing is is that um a lot of
people
kind of hate on the first year because
that's what was what they put out was
awful awful
hold on which was worse D2 year one or
season of unworthy
oh they don't even get me started with
that I forgot about that that was just
recently we just how this is interesting
this is this is interesting man oh um
but also there wasn't even a season of
unworthy there wasn't even attempt of
something in D1 it was just exactly oh
wow wow I don't want to derail this
because this could go rough all I will
say is that uh wow we have forgotten we
have forgotten oh I will say this I
remember it all I'm just saying I will
say this I will say this I will give you
quality of life improvements I will give
you that to make things more easier
um ease of access stuff like that but I
felt D1 from a hardcore MMO standpoint
with the with the skill trees the
customization then when it gets down to
the raids and we have talked about this
very surprised with uh she's got the
heart you know
in reference when you you did the raids
and you had the raid specific gear that
actually helped I just felt there were
things in D1 that were perfectly done
that didn't necessarily need to be
changed not all things but the majority
of the core mechanics I felt that didn't
need to be changed at some I think they
got too cute at the start of d two and
try to simplify things yeah and make you
know and you know I will say this you
know yesterday you guys get to talk now
yeah please do please you were there
were droughts right but why why I differ
Audi is that I feel that what ended up
happening was it was so bad oh yeah he's
got to work y'all
here we go hold on we gotta stop the
show here we go we are getting live and
direct putting the point look at look at
this this is right now we're in a
pandemic y'all we have to stay fit we
have to stay sharp and my man e he took
those points and he's working on that
but look at that tremendous push-up form
did you see that did you see this is the
entertainment we provide here at the
last word you know what I'm saying
you're getting your good cardio in
fantastic Point Redemption y'all
he did it
so I think I think what we've got to
remember as well is that Bungie was very
much under the sum of Activision yes
they were they were faced with fines if
they didn't rely release the content
when they were told to release it like
they were given a time if you don't
release it here we're gonna find you oh
yeah absolutely Beyond light I think is
going to be the first proper
bungee only
expansion I'm sorry
and they're off round two of Point
Redemption we are now doing sit-ups
y'all we had the push-ups we got to get
the court again gotta get core tight
look at the lead placement look at we
going all the way up elbow touching the
knee yes we're really doing this deal
because they put the poison and a man
has to keep sharp so as you can see look
at the cheetah this is fine fine form as
we're working through a pandemic Anubis
is laughing this is what we do here it's
all about Fitness at the campfire y'all
we gotta stay shape because the gym is
not open so you gotta use that personal
gym in the crib he said he's done so no
more points for y'all but he's got two
in for y'all
they cash it in these points either
they're evil
yeah I'm sorry Audi continue your point
I think it's gonna be really super
interesting because beyond my is going
to be the first
um expansion release that's purely
bungee and I feel like this this current
season the season that dropped we're
really starting to get a taste of what
Bungie can produce now right now
obviously
um it's very hard for them to continue
doing what it is that they're doing
because of the fact that they need to
stay home and they're basically yeah
creating and managing this game well in
the safety of their own homes
um I really I genuinely cannot wait to
see what Beyond light would hold
especially excuse me as something is
happening and Beyond light that we've
never had before right an entirely brand
new subclass yes that is yeah I think
this is yeah this is going to be
like I might be too eager and people are
gonna say I Told You So if things kind
of float but I think this is gonna be
the best thing that Bungie has produced
yet and this is why I will always is I
will always I may go away from Destiny
for a little bit yeah we don't go away
live no yeah you know bad Affair no I
hate listen I I hear your points I I
love the future I love the Outlook I
love the fact that they are independent
I think that's great
um like I said about my only point which
I said back to the D1 thing I'll finish
up was just that um the reason why I
can't give D2 over D1 I again like I
said I feel they were a little bit more
hardcore MMO sensibilities involved with
it that I still prefer and D1 where
people can knock it for the droughts I
will say that D1 never had periods where
people were so angry that they like
screw this game okay so the difference
is they didn't have anything to be angry
at
well the difference is the game wasn't
as terrible where they were they were
torching Bungie as if they don't change
this I'm never like they were hate
videos during D2 like they were they
were like what are you doing videos like
we can't we can't we don't get these
versions in D2 okay okay
so that's kind of the thing it's like
when you think of the
The Raid rewards that like some of the
in-game rewards we've talked about this
before and I agree like I want some of
the in-game rewards to have raid
specific perks like the armor sets that
we got a tease of in Gambit Prime give
me armor sets in lots of places and
that's like an idea that's Fallen to the
Wayside unfortunately
um
and yeah we had some of that in D1 we
had bigger gaps as well and there were
like Revolutions of like the
questification of
um taken King that was something that
gave people a lot of long-term stuff to
do yes but in turn we've been getting
continual new stuff to do as well
has everything hit no has everything I
mean what was the April update for
taking King that was pretty small and we
did have a rise of iron but there was
next to nothing after that so but I
think the issue is is it's we're we're
comparing content droughts
versus actual content delivered content
delivered when it came out in D1 for the
most part
it was good you know what I'm saying
like I don't I don't remember there
being when it dropped you know that
people were like yo this is terrible
content you guys need to rework this you
need to rethink this the word bungee
Summits during D1 but we got to talk
about what you're doing wrong and why
this is incorrect and that's what I'm
trying to say they was there were times
when I felt people really killed the
game now I hear your point though in
reference to you know like look there's
there's nothing to do I've done
everything that to me D1 was one of
those things like I've done it all it
was great but now what and you can't
facilitate this this this content coming
in all the time but to me that I rather
that than oh my God what a season of
unworthy and and you know like curse of
Osiris and you know what I'm saying like
it was some bad moments in D2 like
really bad moments so would you would
you prefer no content like nine months
of nothing
yes really if every time you give me
great content when you do drop
I I prefer that
whoa I have to
disagreeable Destiny to me is a
constantly moving world and if we have
to wait nine months for for another
update to the world that we're supposed
to play which basically to me I know a
lot of content creators play this game
every day right
played as often as we play it
I feel that
if it would genuinely kill the game if
we went back to nine months without
anything added to the game I was like
we're exaggerating with dive bumps but
I've been like that fast it was never
enough said he went that lover over like
that first
I mean dude rise of iron and nothing you
had taken King in an April update D1 had
the two expansions that's correct but
the other two years were minimal for the
majority of the year I would say okay so
little to nothing for most of it so well
like maybe you would say well maybe
every every four or five months there
was a little something added to the game
after an expansion right I think that
would kill the game I think that would
uh how we are now
I would definitely kill it now if we
were still on console if PC wasn't a
huge thing I think Destiny would be a
lot healthier right now
and I think interesting honestly I think
um PC it's while PC itself is not the
issue I think that
Bungie encountered so many issues with
PC
um
because it's a different game I
understand that listen I I I like the
evolution I'm not against don't I don't
want to make this seem like I'm against
the evolution of what has happened now I
think they're in a good place I think
that um ultimately you know as a live
service game yeah you would like content
but I think they were in the beginning
of D2 they were trying to find that
happy space when we talked about you
know The Drifter like for example that
was another example of you know when a
whole season is locked to two modes you
know just going back and forth we had to
tell them like look this is cool but you
know we need still need to evolve I
still think they were finding themselves
during the whole period of D2 to now
where we're getting to a good place you
got prophecy you got all this stuff you
gotta raid and stuff like that I think
they're getting there you know I'm
saying I will give you this though I
will give you forsaken was amazing I
think that's arguably you know The
Shining Light for for the thing I
thought shadow shadow keep was solid I
still felt you know the the acceptance
yeah the way I look at D2 is because we
have to be honest too we got people like
cathallion and people who say look I'm
not playing D2 until it's September or
November until it's the big expansion
there's still people who I feel in the
that are hardcore and Destiny community
that won't play the seasonal content and
even though I do feel it's improved you
know say I I do feel it's improved but I
think like I said they're still finding
their way I like it but you know it's
just difference between that's all just
a little can I can I do another spicy
spicy let's spice it they're not
hardcore players if they're not playing
the content through
if you're dedicated to the game you're
gonna see each season through now some
people burn it and switch like I mean
we've both gone through and worked on
ghost of sushima because this season had
a sad you know some UPS some downs but
you're still some people still stay at
only just at arm's length though is be
like okay it's time for a little Destiny
you know I'm gonna take a little space
but they're always never too far some
people like put in the attic for a month
or two and then go get it back out like
that's or nine months depending on if
they come back for the big stuff you
have the people that show up for like oh
we got a new raid cool we got this one
and stuff like that
and again four seconds here with the
multiple Studios and like three
different raids in there that was an
insane year as well and I don't expect
that either so we're in this weird point
so I kind of wanted to ask you guys it's
like a compromise and the timing of
Beyond light being delayed might
actually be something they do I don't
know if they will or not
um but when it comes to the seasonal
pieces if every three months is almost
too fast for them to polish it all like
take that extra month and maybe it's two
drops in the middle maybe they're more
like trimesters going through and you
get like four months and four months and
four months as opposed to three three
three three
like what you see would you would you be
okay with that spacing for both you guys
to say hey it's a four month Gap we only
get two you know content dumps in
between but those have a little more
meat to them there's a little spacing in
between so there's a little down time
but not too much
what do you guys think
Adi I like that I think that would be
good every three months feels like it's
a bit they put themselves in a bit of a
crunch four months but a little bit more
they'd have to balance it so they aren't
just feeling like there's still a crunch
but they've got four months between each
contact drop
but I feel that
la like releasing three different rates
um
was
like part that was due to the demand of
the community we are always we devour
things so fast we expect instant
gratification now because it's
gaming has changed so much especially in
the last like five ten years
so I think that um
I would love I would love it for
um
two raids a year
one expansion kind of like how they're
doing this coming year as far as I'm
aware Vogue won't be landing straight up
I think it might be like six months in a
year maybe the not the
I think the season following yeah no
um I think they need to do that I think
they need to one read at the very start
now I will I will die on this hill if I
have to but I need to stop releasing
raids three days after the expansion
drops yes they need to put it a couple
of weeks ahead now so my my whole
thought process behind this wipe the
bounties wipe anything that's an
inventory that ho that holds XP change
the XP and how it works yeah you need to
reward people for doing activities not
for completing blinging bounties
um of course that's like that's
everybody kind of agrees with that get
rid of the bounties you know like the
hoarding just get rid of that we don't
need that not if we have like two weeks
before the first raid drops right how
like content creators
content creators especially if they want
to take place in like a world's first or
day one clear
they have to rush through the content
yep right and
Bungie is partly a fault for that yeah
because they hype up the world's Races
they hype all that kind of stuff up and
it's like if you give us something
really me and an expansion
right and we we're
um we're you know working our way
through it but we have the ability to
take your time and really soak in the
game like I mean
did either of you participate on a
world's first with a garden or did you
race to get ready for that you couldn't
really enjoy the content could you
because you in the back of your brain
you were more like okay I need to get
this done this done this done this done
this done yeah yeah move on to the next
one this one this one this one this one
this one and stuff like that I feel that
um
they need to start
spacing I release and then raid release
and I think that's that's going to be a
little bit more beneficial for the game
in general as well because there's going
to be more people that are going to want
to try and rate because
they've got the time to prepare for that
you know but
the
the contest modifier is spot on I
actually love the contest modifier I do
too because it doesn't matter how high
you get to right there's a cap when you
yeah give me the time to get there take
your time Love friend maribella's power
per hour thing kills me every time I
hear it
um but yeah take here to like maybe you
take two weeks maybe you take this and
that's kind of the whole idea is like
people how big can that world's first
race get like the skilled people like
the glads the redeemed stuff like that
there's skill there's like a Synergy
between the people who play together
they're still probably going to be
towards the top besides you know a
casual groups who'd be like hey I played
for three weeks I'm ready to go you're
still gonna get your you know you're
still gonna get stepped on when you jump
in there because you're not used to
playing together you don't have that
like raid flow and calling each other
out and knowing each other that well
that the top teams are still going to be
the top teams but on the other side more
people would have an opportunity to jump
in as you said contest levels that
playing field still makes it a pain in
the ass
um
just because like you can't overpower it
and like that the time and spread it and
like have like the way they did dreaming
City like week one week two week three
yeah the infinite rotation I hope
sometimes fixed but like build the story
over a couple weeks with story as well
to build into it to be like hey if we go
to Beyond light we go to Europa hey this
thing unlocks second week okay maybe the
pyramid ship we actually get to explore
it we did something this week and it
opens up then when we get in the pyramid
then we somehow get access to the red
like have it progress over a couple
weeks with a little bit of lore to touch
into it with the story yes and you're
like that's cool give everybody time to
enjoy some of the content try out some
of the new things and not be people like
know Life the game for four days without
sleep and then go that's what that's
what a lot of them do yeah it's like you
you I mean how much focus and Subs can
like you literally like I mean how much
like any of those but it's like you only
need so much caffeine and those weeks
are rough for everybody who tries it's
it's
it's grind it's definitely grind when
they when they uh raid traps you know
the content drops on Tuesday the
raindrops on a Friday or whatever it's
definitely you know intense I I hate
what you guys coming from you know it's
uh it's interesting to see if um they
will actually change that I wonder the
thought process behind it um whether it
be world first if they're marketing wise
trying to capitalize on a new expansion
and then saying you know what the the
fever pitches now let's continue this
there's got to be a reason as to why
they don't put not saying I agree with
it I'm saying like they push it so
quickly as soon as the content drop as
opposed to waiting a week or a couple
weeks or whatever but I do agree with
your argument as far as leading into the
raid like one of the coolest things I
felt even though this wasn't raid was
that when they led into the dreaming
City and they led into the cycle of the
of the dungeon and stuff like that and
that opened that up like that's thing
those are things that are really cool
lore wise where it's just really
seamless is
it makes sense so I would definitely
love them to do that with uh with race I
think that would be really cool I think
it would be interesting to see so part
of the reason they probably release the
raid so quickly is because they are
miners so what I would be interested to
see is that
a more solid
space between like a more solid
like up update between grades yeah and
and so Tuesday you hit the update hits
you upload it it's all the information
that you need for the expansion but the
red stuff isn't in there right right
like so a couple of weeks later so the
other thing that I really enjoy about
the thought of having a couple weeks
later is that the only thing that's
going to separate you between the ones
that have hoarded boundaries and stuff
the only thing that's going to separate
you guys from the top tier teams is
skill and teamwork that's what you're
saying earlier that's really the only
thing that's going to
if you have if people are actually
grinding and leveling and you know the
really because if they want to do it
they will grind oh yeah you know but
having that the having the 20 minutes at
not 20 sorry I just read 20 minutes in
the chat
having the two weeks out it enables more
people to get on that grounded and
there's going to be more people going
for it and in the end it is legitimately
going to be down to skill and teamwork
not how high your light level is and
everything like that and I know we kind
of already have that with the artifact
but frankly I would rather enjoy playing
the playing the the expansion and stuff
like that and spending half of my time
in a lost sector grinding by nice to
make sure that I'm at least at the
minimum light level for the first
encounter yeah um
I think that um
oh what was I gonna say
so the the my idea behind the the
um a more solid line between the
expansion update and the raid update
right so
obviously data miners are a bit of a
pain yeah apart for me personally I
don't like data mining I don't like
spoilers I don't like any of that so
Tuesday the expansion drops are updates
it's all about it's basically all the
game you know it's it's the it's that
expansion job but anything pertaining to
the raid isn't in there right right and
then you've got
the day of the raid Destiny gets taken
down
keep going keep going yeah the update
get some gets deployed
um you know you upload it hour after
so you get all the you get that last
minute stuff that you may need to do
after reset an hour after that that's
when the raid goes live yeah oh yeah
hang up on your screen goes live that's
it you can go straight in there and
there you go
they need to have the the different they
just need to have the files separate
right because if you constantly have
data miners going in and finding out the
stuff about it people are gonna have
there they are gonna have an unfair
Advantage so no completely agree I mean
that this has been plaguing them for so
long right this this whole data mining
thing and again I'm not trying to knock
any content creator who is getting you
know your view count because of this you
know Yo God bless you I'm not sure it's
gonna get two weeks later it's not like
the race
I agree there is something deflating
when you do find out already you know
saying what everything is going to be or
how something is going to play out and
stuff like that and you missed that
surprise aspect you do miss that you
know that General sense of you know what
is gonna happen and it takes away from
people's hard work let's be honest you
know what I'm saying like they've worked
Bungie worked very hard on this content
so if there was a way that they could
separate these updates and so that
they're not be able to date them I just
don't know logistically how their Studio
Works how they Implement you know uh
expansions you know updates and stuff
like that but if there is a way they
could do it yes I I would love for them
to do that so this way you all got that
fresh experience you don't know what's
about to happen that'd be really cool
that'll be really cool but Dale Mitchell
says you do really as the developers
have to play for a separate update it
may be a cost thing it may there may be
some logistic thing that we may not
privy to as to why it's done the way it
is because I would assume they cannot
like when these videos come out and like
here are the four new Exotics that's
coming here's the like everyone's just
data mining everything out of it I feel
like
um
we already
a part of the price that we pay with
Beyond light would be part of it would
be for the raid they just separate it
so like say without the red say it's
like 15 or 20 dollars cheaper and then
and so you then separate the player base
I mean well I mean no what I'm what I
mean is is it more when you pre-order
when you pre-order Beyond light right
you're basically you're paying the
development fees you're paying
everything like that and you're paying
for the game itself for the hard work
and everything right so if you
um
if since the the
um the teams are charged per update
they could
so when you pre-order
you could I you're paying for everything
essentially right and then you're you'd
be covering the
um
maybe covering the developing fee for
the the rate drop okay I don't know I I
feel
I get what what Neil's seen with um that
they have to pay for the different
updates and stuff but I think that
it might be healthier for the game but
that would be down to Bungie to decide
that and whether that ends up and I was
paying like a little bit more like when
you look at the the update and what
percentage of how much we pay
is
to do with it
um how much like so basically how much
how much you pay how much of a
percentage of that is to pay for the
developer fee like how much is actually
a developer fee to
um
to run this thing this is what I'm what
I'm curious about is that right like is
it 10 is it twenty percent so sixty
dollars how much of that
um is going towards the developing fees
and how much is going towards the studio
itself and right the wages for the
um
I mean it's a tough one that that it's a
tough one you know it's hard like
Logistics and how they can separate that
and I don't know I don't know I mean now
I guess my to ask a question to you in
reference to you you want you you were
trying to go with it being separate for
in terms of the race specifically I was
trying to get where your mindset was
with that you you want it as a separate
entity from the on the update or
in a perfect world you know how would
you how would you want it I would want
the the update files for the radar
itself and all the information that it
hold to be separate gotcha fair enough
because data miners would get in there
and they discover things that that need
to be that
we
um
basically just make sure that the data
Miners and the hackers and everything
um don't have as much an advantage the
other the other benefit to that is if
you actually have a paywall between
raids
um it stopped it could potentially stop
cheaters because so you get that you've
got the cheaters in trials and stuff
like that and the reason that the cheats
are watching is because they can earn
money from it yeah I'm with you on
Trials big time on Trials yeah trials
something
so much so you've got you've got the
tutors and trials and the reason that
they can just go up and pick up their
prescription for perfect aim is just
because they earn so much money taking
like cutting people Flawless and it
doesn't matter and even if you I don't
think putting a paywall to trials is
actually really going to help that
because they earn so much however if you
look at
if you look at maybe
increasing how much you pay because I
mean to be when you look at it the
prices of games are going up anyway
again
so if you if you were to look at paying
slightly more
and it kind of paywalls the rate I'm not
saying like a hardcore
a hardcore paywall but we
we're gonna have to start if Bungie
aren't going to keep going with the
if they're holding back on an Ichi
because they can't develop their own
properly on time right either they need
to look at a third party right like I
think it's easy eye or something yeah
you need to look at a third party or
they need to start taking more steps
between paywalls and maybe taking the
game off free to play because it's just
been it's been horrific I have seen so
much like my cards have been filed yeah
PC's been awful trials it's been
this is the thing is this
is a one
one platform that's causing most of the
issues and I don't think Bungie was
fully prepared for that
um the other but it's not just Bungie to
be clear better cheers
uh running rampant in every game right
now Warzone I've heard is particularly
bad
um I get that they want free to play
because they wanted to increase the
player base right but I think they've
kind of they've diminished their loyal
player base because of what they did
yeah it's a good argument in PvP it's a
it's a it's a valid I mean you've got
the online population you know influx
which you they do like they do like the
uh the community coming in but the the
curse of it is obviously you know the
ease of access the ease of entry into
you know trials and hardcore activities
and really making life miserable for
people who are not cheating you know
it's it's a PC is going to be tough it
that that's always going to be the
struggle there and I don't know if it's
a paywall I don't know if it's a hard
anti-cheat software that has to be
installed it they're in a tough spot
they're in a tough spot with it to how
to handle it you know I mean so because
I see both arguments yeah but the
problem that we now have is that we're
worried about things that have no
monetary value we're worried about that
in the PVE Community taken away
because now we have this
there is a potential that cheaters will
get worlds first now
whether bungee now have to make a rule
where if you want to be viable for a
world's first title you have like one or
two members of your team have to be
streaming it's just um
it's
very concerning when we're worried in a
game that is it in the pde side of
things we're about a massive achievement
being taken away because people have
automatic
um automatic like revokers or whatever
it is oh my God yeah yeah and you know
um
and I hope that they honestly they're
they're being too silent for most of the
community to really
feel like they're being heard I really
would I like they haven't touched on it
on like maybe the past three twabs
um oh yeah I was watching as to cross
like was he gonna do a twab or not or
was he gonna do a 12 videos like up nope
another 12 no anti-cheat see you guys
later that's what he was actually
starting to do that for a couple weeks
because there are so many and they are
big content creators that get tired of
it I mean you watch a lot of the hugely
renowned PVP players uh content creators
streamers all those
and they just get so tired of it I mean
Cognito and I joked like literally the
first day before this started make him
pay for like make some way to pay either
pay the buy the season pass to pay for
trials uh make some ridiculously long
quests where we're like I don't know get
a stupid number of kills in PvP before
you go into trials before you can
actually just like jump in so these like
new accounts find some way to stop the
new accounts like recoveries is a whole
different ball of wax and Ruby huh or
just lock it into the season pass just
you have to
like you only have access to trials
trials itself nothing else you only have
access to trials if you buy the season
pass season pass is not that expensive
yeah so but like there has to be
something I'm sorry I didn't mean to cut
you off at times my brain there like
they're kind of like or even an add-on
like and I know that's really unfair
because PVP players that play trials
would then have to end up forking out
more when Bungie should be the ones that
are really providing the safe
environment that they can play without
coming across hackers I run with the
fizzle every weekend because he's kind
enough to take me through trials and he
has a 10 into like 100 into like suit
that he has to put on and Mountaintop
and everything to combat just cheers and
and everything like that like some of
it's just been wild right yeah it's
really bad I was like as gmd's saying
it's like a lot of things and I think a
Little's in there because I can't
remember who tweeted it might have been
lucky or something and they were like
they literally watched somebody like
respawn and respawn they were cheating
that way and then they got kicked they
actually watched somebody get kicked
live by cheating so it's like there
there's little things in the background
but as he's saying it's like the
anti-cheat software but depending for
some because you watch like do maternal
or valorant was like almost like into
like so d deep into the hardwood they're
almost getting like almost at a bias
level that people are like you don't
want you that far in my computer you're
still just yeah okay performance as well
right because that also and I want to
I've seen GMD not the country but I see
his point I'm just saying that these are
options they have they have to be
considering and then also you know we
have to keep in fact they went to
another platform right they went to
steam you know then they have this is
not a solo effort right this is they
have to work in conjunction with the
platform that it is on this is a very
complicated I'm not excusing them you
know but it to Audi's point
we're at the point where the Integrity
of the game is at stake absolutely and
right now it is not anyone's desire to
look at a world first and hear about
people getting bumped off as we found
out recently through uh you know
and ddosing and stuff like that you know
trials is a mess the PVP Community has
been suffering you know I'm part of that
and it it it really sucks that you don't
take it with that level of seriousness
now what they did say that they're going
to work on it it did they gave us kind
of a road map as far as how long maybe
but and they they also said they can't
talk about it so it's just a weird thing
because like we don't want to talk about
it together they can't tell you what we
do yeah but we are doing something and
it's just like they always say they're
like they've banned thousands of people
but it's just it never seems like enough
to a point I haven't jumped in Trials
but I only hear it's terrible that's the
reason I haven't jumped in the thing is
is that I I have seen people say that
they uh they've reported someone for
cheating about four months ago and they
still continue still running around yeah
it's demoralizing and it's to the point
now and I I know we went crazy
I'll I'll wrap up I'll wrap up this um
for me but um it's to the point now
what's sad is when you play someone now
even if it's a good play you don't know
I'm sure I want to give you props
a guy was a hell of a shot and I'm like
I don't even want to go like dig into
stats to figure out if he was like I
don't yeah but I hate in the background
mine that is there like the fact that
the float just the the float the thought
floats through my mind for a second to
be like was because I'm like some people
are like damn good slide shots and don't
even get me started if I'm shooting
somebody like five bullets into
something and they still can snap me I'm
like your reticle should be somewhere
else but that's a whole different animal
that's that's sniper Flinch and that
needs to be fixed yeah I agree I agree
but
but yeah it's just uh I agree uh it's
just it sucks that you you have that
question because you're like oh I'm on
PC I always hear there's a bunch of
cheaters it's like might just run around
and control and somebody's just like
what getting his numbers up like it
doesn't I don't even know why you'd use
it there but it's like now you question
it for no reason
it is demoralizing in PvP when you're
like I don't know if that shot was legit
or if it was
you know it's sad I love PVP so much I'm
the most above average player but I love
Visa PVP it's just definitely PVP just
hits the sweet spot for me personally
you know what I'm saying as far as it's
it's it's in the middle it's like you
know you still have a hardcore aspect to
it but the fact that it has abilities
and all this other fun stuff you could
do to change the tide and then when
you're playing against people who are
doing things in Iron banner and basic
bolds and you're just like really this
is what we're doing you know it's tough
man I I feel for them you know it's it
it's going to be a tough way to
implement it but hopefully they can come
up with something because they got to
save it they gotta save that that aspect
of the game they're just gonna be more
vocal they've just got like even a small
update that's why I'm saying we're
making progress or we've had a they need
to be more force fight with them
completely agree for like we have you
know we've encountered an issue trying
to start on a cheat so we're working on
this is again they don't even have to
give us General specifics but they are
just they're treating on a cheat like
it's not not there at all like it's not
a problem or I mean that's that's how it
seems because they're refusing to
mention it in the twap like even if they
were just like hey we've got this kind
of issue going on right now so we're
attempting to fix that or
um we've run in a couple of bugs in the
in in how we're trying to
um build the sound Ichi or hey we've
made some Progressive we're about a
percentage closer or just just something
right they just need to give us
something to be able to say that they
are acknowledging on itchy like yeah
sure they've said that they're working
on it and they're acknowledging it in
something that was three or four trials
ago and you know what the destiny
Community is like it's like oh are you
actually doing something or are you just
giving us lip service hello we hear you
at least a few years it's like okay the
words went in they may have been
processed but I didn't get anything on
the other side
um
before we as like we could fall down
this rabbit hole for so so much longer
it's crazy uh but before we transfer to
over actually all the stuff we've been
doing this week which we haven't even
got to so this is good podcast but I'm
sorry
no you're good okay discussion yeah all
good stuff uh had a very specific
question so Addie
um yes
peanut butter
I we have a question about peanut butter
what's the deal
I don't like peanut butter I had um
one of my my inflammatory stream titles
was uh
peanut butter sucks
Wow Wow
in your life no um
what's going on talk to us I just so I
just don't so I like drive off roasted
peanuts I like salted peanuts peanut
butter is just too rich I can't stand it
so it was just a simple peanut butter
sauce and oh my goodness do people feel
strong have you have you had a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
no
Jelly's the balance girl you gotta try
it you gotta get inside it so jelly to
me is wibbly wobbly stuff that you have
from an ice cream with ice cream at a
children's party okay
okay then put some peanut butter and
marmalade together
fine I'll do I'll do it at some point
I'll record it and I'll tell you how I
feel okay oh my God that's what we just
got we gotta let's give Peanut Butter a
lot of things we have the salt and the
sweet and you combine those two together
and it kind of gets a nice balance
between them so exactly shout out to
Donuts
so we're gonna get we're gonna get Addy
to try it we go we go see the results
you heard it here first or the last one
Crystal what are you doing to us
are we gonna ask every guest who comes
through the question
you have any short thoughts on that the
way it's coming back
that's it let me go ahead and put that
away perfect that was a great Capital
answer
we've got a treaty we're good all right
excellent that's been like a two and a
half week debate so I'm glad chaos chaos
you're asking no chaos for you today
Crystal's like the Joker he just wants
to watch the world burn yeah he's like
Twisted the knife I don't know what
you're doing Crystal we see you so
somehow we talked for almost an hour and
40 minutes and we still haven't even
talked about what we've been doing this
entire week oh dear did your podcast
normally go for our podcast is usually
about two like you I will say like
normally we're about two hours of some
people like yeah I should be able to
stay around that long we've had some
people hang for three but I was like
you're used to three hours so you're
just like go whatever well we'll talk
and if it turns out we just need to cut
things off then we'll just go hey we'll
be back for part two next week
yeah uh well the podcast used to be
called Flashpoint and then we joke it
was a long point so we've been there
we've done that so it's fine oh yeah
but Solstice of Heroes so obviously it
came out you guys have seen the watch of
the video background
uh yeah we've had a couple controversial
pieces a couple bugs go on before we get
into the things that have gone you know
a little up in the air and could have
been fixed over overall just thoughts of
it this year the way it returned we're
going to the EAS you got the objectives
on the armor where do you guys overall
thoughts on the grind the feel of it are
you doing it do you not care thoughts
Patty you're first because you're the
guest and ladies
it's something to do I don't know I
don't I don't feel the right that's a
low bar man yeah she said it low
like there's there's no mod Rush to do
it because we've got three weeks
um
so
it's not it's definitely not as good
ideas it was last year which is a
suppose a plus I enjoy the fact that
they've actually put up a bonus so once
you complete the first one if you do the
second one you've got a times two you do
the third you've got a times three I
think that's really really smart because
no one wants to sit and do the same
thing on three characters and it'll take
the same amount of time that should be
like everywhere in the game by the way I
fully support that all places I agree
quality of life like you know if you've
already done something don't make them
do it again
um I love the EAS itself that's a very
it's a very very cool Skybox and the
fact is is that you got a very distinct
different times of these day and night
and that's really really fun I enjoy
that
um
killing the bosses I wish that we had
new bosses
I feel like all I've seen is the ones
from last year it feels like almost a
direct copy and paste from last year
yeah
um and I get it's literally it's to fill
it's basically it's content okay get
something to drop and it's something for
people to do and to chase I'm not a big
fan of the fact that when you complete
the Masterwork when you complete the the
objectives plus Majestic it doesn't
Masterwork your armor oh you're you're
ahead of me but yeah that was like
probably my biggest win down to my sales
on this one I think I don't understand
why we have to
spend more materials when we've spent
that much time grinding it but I enjoy
the fact that
um
I I enjoy the fact that once if you get
all three characters to that particular
step once you complete a step on the
Majestic armor it's completed on the
others that I enjoy what I hate
is how much we would have to spend in
the eververse to get the subclassical
glows for every character that
is unacceptable I think I
I I know the ever verses for helping to
support the game and stuff but that to
me now I'm I buy things from eververse
all the time I don't shy away from every
verse that's where I get a lot of pretty
things
but that was money grabbing and I'm not
a fan of that I'm not absolutely I mean
I don't know pounds like I don't know
how much it is for you guys it's for the
three sets it's 45 bucks
yeah so like the expansion is what
shadow keep base price or not Shadow
keep uh Beyond light base price for 50.
um
three armor sets or your entire
you know September expansion of things
and that's
and this is the whole I mean micro
transactions are in a weird place right
now they talk about game prices going up
from 60 to 70 which is like in my
opinion long long over two
um
[Music]
I would disagree but that's an entirely
difference yeah that's a whole podcast
in itself yes
a whole whole different one but in
general like to me and I've said this
like if some of this stuff was cheaper I
would probably buy even more
if I felt like it was getting a good
value for my money and I'm sitting here
looking at these glows now granted the
glows I will say they said people have
had some feedback like hey these don't
look so hot they're not really good like
they're not they're not that glowing
they said they're looking into that so
that is one thing they're looking at we
also had the bug of the two times and
three times progression for Titans that
I almost got screwed on but switched
over to Warlock and now I'm back on my
Titan so there's that little bit of
stuff going on
um about forty five dollars I'm just
sitting there like my Titan's my main I
usually made my Titan so it's like 15
bucks for the seat for the you know for
the event I could probably do that and I
know there are fortnite skins that are
twenty dollars
that's fine that's a free game and I
can't remember who I was listening to
talk about it's like they they almost
triple dip you get your expansion you
get your season pass then you have the
eververse it's one too many transactions
it feels like all the time
I feel
copy and
so why are we paying even more money to
get the same thing that we had last year
I understand that it looks different I
understand but it's slightly different
to what it was last year but I feel and
I know that it's enabled
like it's got a pre-enability like you
can get the sub the stasis school on it
as well when you finally get stasis
right but it's ridiculous that they are
expecting us to pay 45
or use basically your entire bright dust
store because yes sure there is a free
way to get it it should not be 15 per
character oh and you can't you can't
even grind bright dust right now because
the event doesn't have bright dust on
the bounties hello
and they're like they're also checking
into that and I'm just going those are
like the bugs that I'm like I understand
not everything's perfect but that
like the longer it takes the more that's
an issue I think there they missed a
really really good opportunity to get
more people involved in the game if they
had just as soon as you complete the big
masterworked armor that's when you get
your goal or Like A step above that so
yeah I mean what if it was even sorry to
cut you off what if it was even
something for the arc solar and void
like hey while wearing the full set of
armor which you can Infuse up to 360. so
you're gonna have plenty of time uh you
know you get so many kills with whatever
to start unlocking the other colors now
it could be like a ridiculous number of
kills you know to a point where it's
like balanced over the course of maybe
the first season next year but on the
other side it's
like that would be a way to say you
could spend some money still bring the
price down it's too damn much but on the
other side if you get the white glow and
you're like hey I want to activate the
blue glow well go get 2 000 Arc subclass
kills while wearing the full set of
armor
do it if it was like if it was something
like that you know they'd just be paying
shiruchi a visit
so I was like I I don't know how you do
it maybe you gotta go complete some more
you know 10 more Gambit matches or
something that like you know I know well
you don't mind but
[Laughter]
I don't know the exact way to make it
earnable but give the alternative for
people who are willing to put in the
time especially if it's gonna last for
the next 10 months or however long it's
gonna last when you get it let somebody
who would even a casual that can just
play like 50 however many strikes it
what it doesn't need to be stupid but
make it earnable like you can buy or you
can go earn due to lots of plant time
and that's again still keeping people in
your game doing what they're going for
anyway yeah that's it it's the fact that
like if they're offending if they're
finding an issue with like the player
base going down and stuff they need to
encourage people to stay in the game not
spend their money like
if it was slightly cheaper I would
totally go for it but I don't feel like
as a as a single parent
who the only way that she earns her
money is by streaming I don't feel like
I have the ability to drop 45 on some
cosmetic stuff even though it's really
it's really pretty and I really want it
it's a really pretty and I really want
it but I also have bills to pay 15 per
character is Extreme I feel like it
should only be five
or maybe ten but the thing is is that um
even if you were to put it as ten
dollars your pricing
an expansion almost you're pricing like
Cosmetics are almost the same price
season pass yep that's confusing to me
like I have seen Exotics
like exotic emotes be like
1000 silver what justifies that exotic
you know as if as ten dollars that's not
even like if it's a pack of three if
they were to put a pack of three emotes
into the eververse as one thousand
silver I'd buy it straight off because
I'm getting three not just one
yep I'm with you like cheaper
cheaper stuff especially more places to
earn some bright dust like both sides
would help and they've gone so far the
other way it's
it hurts the way it is lately because
yeah those like ten dollar I mean you
look at like the big ax finisher that we
get with this emote which I'm sure you
looked at do you already own it Cognito
or not yet
did you purchase you bought it already
I'm weak
and I bought the bed in the needling and
that yeah yeah they they got me they got
me they got me it certain ones it just
speaks to me oh I know the iron Lord one
makes sense they can charge you fifty
dollars and you can still do it because
you don't care ones that people were
coming up to me like yo you don't got to
bend the knee you're an iron Lord like
what's going on you know you know how it
goes you're gonna say but look at the
end of the day I am Prescott bro you
know there's certain ones that they make
it just touches your soul and you just
say okay you got this one you got this
one budget but to your point like the
pricing is definitely out of whack
nothing should be on the level of the
expansion or a season pass
way too much
fortnite's free to play other games in
the new cosmetic I mean what's a Path of
Exile the armor sets in there almost
like 50 bucks but my buddy's like every
so often they'll do like and but the
whole thing's free to play he'll play
like hundreds of hours like leveling up
his character and dump like 50 bucks in
for like a full like giant season of
content because that's the only thing
he's paying for we pay for the expansion
for the seasons and for Cosmetics
Cosmetics like
you would see a whole lot of two and
three dollar charges on my card yeah if
I was like buying like hey here's a
thousand silver I got these oh man it's
only 10 more bucks well I can get like
four more things cool okay like I would
do that more now granted there's the
other side where there's the whales and
they have some statistics where they
price it the way they do but oh
absolutely yeah absolutely this is all
business right yeah that's what they're
doing you know I'm not saying it's right
I mean it's just one of those things
that now I think as a result that
they've gotten more out of control it's
just more now you become selective
there's things that you like you might
want but I'm like I'm only getting the
things I'm in my opinion like I feel I
must have you know what I'm saying but
yeah it's it comes down to it until the
um EAS you know with the whole um
solstice
I'm glad it's back I've been playing it
you know I started my grind late
I do missed it I miss it because when I
started the EAS I I instantly reminded
me how much I love the verticality of
that level and it's just you know
they're searching I am one of the few
people that actually don't mind the
Easter hunt thing like I don't know it's
a treasure hunt at the end I know people
hate it I'll be honest I'm not a fan I
don't know
Earth ghost
use your what the Earth ghost you know
they'll detect your chests and stuff
like that use that works
the EDC earth goes work there you go
oh I did not do this oh it is so on
that leaves it up a little bit I guess
part of it is okay so not everybody
knows that there are however many people
are watching that now know that but for
a lot of General people it's like you go
through and like cool you even got like
some boss runs and stuff and then you
get like I picked up three chests what
are we at four what are the other two
stupid people in this group doing right
now but yeah it's fun though it makes me
laugh because I'm like that's not fun
that's frustrating
I have two dumbasses in my group sorry
I'm the one cussing today and Addie was
worried about it I know she was like I'm
gonna be cleaning
yeah no no she's like no no not me
no it's just like it's frustrating to me
like to go through and again not
everybody knows yes the ghost will help
that'll be good so I can help some but
I'll like I'm gonna like try and do a
quick pan over like half I'm gonna go
around pick up a couple some dude looks
the same direction I go I'm like oh and
then like we find like three and some
other dude I swear is just like staring
at his phone in the corner just like I
don't know what is he doing that's not
me I swear
they change in there they change the
chess locations
so it was like you have they did change
some of the chess locations so not all
but some are different okay
okay there's one I know on a roof that I
have not seen there's one in a little
hallway that so I heard there was a
couple that changed maybe not all they
changed some okay yeah
um I've yet to witness it myself but
he knows yeah Aries is yeah Aries is
running it quick we got like 13 bosses
down 13 chest runs getting optimal runs
in there wow yeah I gotta run with
chocolate wow yeah killing it yeah so
it's like it can be done officially but
overall just for the event for me it is
copy paste no it's copy paste like not
much different and then I will say like
the grind on the armor did get it got
better things were tweaked a little bit
I wish it was Gambit or Crucible for the
second tier just to give you variety a
little bit because they do that on some
things it would nice to just be see a
little yeah a little bit
um a little bit of variety but I was
like they took out what was it like 50
packages or something look people were
like farming that one Scion remember
that one Scion boss we have to yeah yeah
yeah so it's like that that was fixed
um so some things are better and then
you get the kind of egregious eververse
costs get a little bit in there but we
also had like the progression Edition
like the second third characters as you
guys were saying those are fantastic I
love the fact that that's in there it
sucked for a day or two because it was
like Titan Titan stop your Titan it's
broken crap but it was fixed within like
a day and I was like that's impressive
so it's like they jumped on a bug fairly
quickly too and I saw somebody be like
wow they actually fixed a bug for the
players this fast as opposed against us
for one so it's like oh man I mean
they're not wrong so like it's it's
genuinely like there's some to be fair
we don't I mean there's probably some
Guardians in the community they also do
clothing and also do bugs and everything
like that so they'll know but to most of
us we're never really Gonna Know
how much
um testing and
tweaking that they have to do before
they can actually fix a problem so
the Titan bug was probably really simple
to fix but you know another bug that may
seem like really simple and also really
annoying to us could be buried in like
six pages of code absolutely and break
other things yeah is it server-side
which they did that like background
server main incidents things seemed to
get fixed later I was like I wonder if
that was tied together and then some are
truly client-side where we have to get a
patch just as we were talking about
patches take time for certification for
all the consoles like some things are
not going to be fixed and then they what
was the thing they talked about
it was taking them forever to track down
oh there was something with like snipers
and like the way the bounce there was
something that they were trying to
figure out for it was an older patch I
can't remember
but it was one that they tracked forever
and they like we finally figured
something out here and they're like
you've been thinking about I almost
forgot about it when they brought it up
again some things some things take so
long and you just don't know what it
takes because it was joke about their
spaghetti code but yeah every system in
that whole thing is tied together
yeah but like I said for me it's just
been like I said I I get it everything
you guys are saying I agree with it is
it is copy and paste I just I think it's
something about I just like that the
event is different from a verticality
standpoint I do like a little bit of the
fun with the um treasure hunt thing now
the thing I dislike
I still not a fan of this armor I think
last year's armor set for me blows this
one away
You're a hunter you're a hunter you'll
see the Warlock speak to me in the chat
when you put on this suit
I'm too big in the hips I don't like the
way like big hips so go do some cardio
like I just did come on yeah like this
warlock me stick to get down with the
squats it needs to do something it needs
to get all the to the treadmill I I just
feel stocky I don't feel very Sleek
warlocks trying to be Sleek it's Hunters
that are meant to be cruel are you a
mentalist female character
for the warlocks in the chat
please tell me if y'all prefer lashes
Solstice gear or this year because I
don't like I like I like the only thing
I like about it is a little crack to
chess piece the the gold the the actual
default color of it but the suit I'm not
there y'all I'm not there talk to me
while locks out I don't know your spidey
I'm with you yeah I don't know I think
you guys got the good end of the stick I
think Hunter is a great Titan's great
but yeah
yeah it's always about the conductor
models as well like I will never not
play like I will never not have a female
model for Hunter not just because of the
gender that I am but also because it
looks better right and that's that's the
truth with with all of the characters
um which you know they're a bit more
slander which makes sense because
traditionally men are larger than women
um
but I I really really like this year's
gear on on all three characters I'll
play all three characters I'm
comfortable in all three characters
um but hunter is normally my main I am a
Titan main right now so I have to make
Titan for for a while because uh it's
like why that doesn't sound like you
yeah it's interesting um because I did a
charity fundraiser for black lives
matter
um but we raised enough money
boyfriend who is a hunter main main
Warlock
my friend Krillin he's a tiny man he has
to mean a hunter and I have to maintain
some
yeah me yes I like partially armor such
as the barn and then Austin cracks yeah
the top part I'm good I just don't like
the Surly arms and and the bottom half
at all but uh that's just me but that's
what it is I think what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to transmog it one second
I'm gonna transmog that bottom half and
that sash is not doing it for me I'm
sorry wall like that helmet I will be
throwing an exotic in that place and
then keeping the rest of the set that's
that's when I got there
that's all not too much of an opinion I
will say though for every one of them
both the Titan like chest and full dress
you got the hunter cloak and then the
Titan Mark every one of those has a big
open loop at the bottom and it feels
like Incredibles Cape is gonna get
caught on something yeah like like just
hold on be like and just yank it right
off but I mean overall
I don't know I was like I yeah you got
hips oh no at least yeah
wow okay all right child bearing hips on
the wall out there I mean you got that
open open bottom dress as well you're
good to go uh not a fan
[Laughter]
I'm not feeling very very fun yeah no
kids oh we got a guest appearance there
we go there we go everybody shout out to
the most valuable player in the podcast
right there making the guest appearance
yes
yes salute
are you without original she is gonna
break a whole lot of guys hearts out
there in the world
hey yeah their hearts will be broken
let's just say that Lots will be broken
hearts will be broken absolutely okay
what do you need to
[Laughter]
eat she's like I need to sleep now I did
want to ask you guys sparrows and ships
now that you've seen them in game the
pictures look good are you guys thinking
about any of The Sparrows and ships
again eververse I know stuff's expensive
but curious if you guys toyed around
are you still on your
are you still on your Sparrow from last
week the one with the big like gold
like swooping ornaments or do you like
the Sleek like Speeder bike
yeah yeah oh yeah definitely I still
like the I think you're as I looked at
it yours does look better when I finally
seen it in front yeah I have to admit
yeah I think yours does look better I
guess the way it was displayed
like the flatter wings but you can't see
it in the picture as well yeah yeah and
then when I saw you I'm like nah ease is
bad I do like so that's my decision on
it I definitely feel that
um what about you Addie what are you
feeling about the uh
what do you run
this battle from Scourge ah because you
got it nice I think it's it's actually
it's just because the utility of it it's
it's hungry it's um
just makes
I don't see the need to continuously
change my spiral and I haven't I
probably haven't changed my my ship
especially on my hunter in a long time
um there really is no point you have 160
sparrow that loads fast cool
that's one of those when we think about
Beyond light it's like hey for one
everything should be 162 they should all
be all fast load so at least you might
consider mixing it up I have my tilt
fuse that I got from the Arms Dealer on
one of my characters and I've left it
there because it's an exotic I'm like
that's fine
something a little different between my
two toots back
I want most battle horns back too oh I
know I missed those somebody even
brought those up and srl's like tweet or
like reply if you know what this is I
was like oh my God I missed the horns
I think Bungie should really take a
lesson because I know a lot of people
the read the ship that I run is the
whisper ship
that was a three-week grind and I got it
and I haven't taken it off it's one of
the best looking ships in this entire
game and I didn't have to pay any silver
or any bright dust for it how do you
need to do more of that yeah and that's
why I like D1 because they used to do
that all stuff all the time
to be fair they only had to manage two
consoles though PC is probably a little
bit more expensive in regards to uh
developing costs and Patch updates and
everything like that so I imagine that
they are trying to they are also using a
reverse funds to create more content
more extensions and stuff absolutely but
they definitely they need to they need
to rewind a little bit and go back I I'm
very much of a you know D2 is a little
bit better than D1 but they do need to
go back to
um their D1 kind of routes with not
relying so much on money
like again they took the eververse armor
out they put it into prophecy dungeon
which yes again like that was a step in
the right direction of at least taking
Cosmetics out putting them earnable in
in-game activities stuff like that but
again yeah also when I go through pit of
heresy I want to look like zomack I
still wish I could but I won't relax
like ADI said it's something it's that
Pride when you got that ship that's only
earnable that way and people like where
did you get that like yo I grinded I did
X Y and Z yeah I I ain't gonna open my
checkbook
that's what a lot of people do it D2 is
checkbook here we go and then they got
everything and I just missed that but
yeah it's so cool that they at least we
get it though they're trying to find the
game and you know we honestly we just
want that nice balance it's that nice
balance
yeah
yeah well I mean I think we kind of
knocked out I mean that's basically
what's going on we got Solstice that is
everything that's happening right now so
as you guys work through your armor
we're working through that uh they had a
bungee Foundation update they have some
they're over
um 1.1 million for everything they got
going from the empathetic Ghost Shell
and all the stuff that they've done for
that iPads for kids program the stuff
that they do is always fantastic so like
the fact that
they did 600 2 000 in donations and 555
000 from the empathetic Ghost Shell
that's insane that was insane that's one
thing that I really like like whatever
verses is that that was that was a
really really good
thing
to put in eververse yep
um that type of stuff is cool same with
like the the shirts they did for the
Australian fighters I love those types
of things I was a good cause they've
been on fire yeah those those pieces
they I don't think anybody touches them
as much as they do for that always so
cool and yeah if you ever need to cry go
read one of those stories because that
definitely like pull out your
heartstrings and you're like
it's like too bad
um got another fashionable week coming
up see if you guys are looking to do
that the solstice fashion show if you
got some some glow and gears and stuff
so players must be wearing at least one
Solstice of Heroes Armor piece doesn't
matter which one no glows are required
players must take a picture on any
destination to qualify that's it so you
can tweet at them through Thursday
August 20th um oh they'll be revealing
them on August 20th I guess tweet at
them as soon as you can
cool other than that they've you know
they've got some missing emblems some
patches they know some stuff that
they're working on generally that's most
of it yeah uh I know they kind of put
out just to wrap this thing up I know
we're going along but kind of do the
final little topic here DMG kind of put
out a tweet and he was asking for just
kind of quick five bullet points that
you want to see here about for
um Beyond light basically what's coming
so for both you guys what are like five
things or do you want to kind of do one
at a time uh that you want to see coming
with Beyond light or that you want to
not even see that you want to hear about
from Bungie what's your we'll do round
robin kind of go one at a time so ADI
um first thing just what comes to your
head is something you want to see with
regards to Beyond light what's the raid
light gonna be
oh what the the required level what the
required level is for red light I'd
really like to know that
that would be interesting
um I think for me also the
implementation of um year one cross play
where it's system the system I want them
to get to talk about that see if they're
gonna hear one cross play what do you
mean well remember they said it's gonna
be two phases right they said uh oh
well I meant to say like um remember how
they said uh Xbox and you know series X
and regular family cross play gotcha
like that just to you know get the the
walls down with that and I know that
next year they'll talk about the big one
but just to see how they Advance with
that that would be cool just some
information on that what about you guys
uh I mean for me just like
there's some little stupid stuff and
I'll just keep thinking stuff as we go
but like what's gonna all the stuff
related to the planets that are leaving
I mean is there like be it currency
currencies that have got the content
involved a lot more clarity on the
content Vault between currencies should
I be dumping all those in aspire to get
stuff that's more valuable uh that type
of stuff you've also got things like the
Thorne Quest just what their plan is for
those types of things just to get a
little more clarity because there's a
lot of people just like
waiting and we have three months and I
can like you know work on some of that
stuff so that's one of mine
Addy and speaking of uh Destiny content
Vault I want to know the lore
I want to know how they're gonna put
that in the lore how they're going to
justify that we are not going to be able
to get honestly I have my own thoughts
on it and I have my own
way that that will happen but I'll be
very interested to see if it lines up
with what they're going to do yep
um for me we discussed earlier
anti-cheat be nice to talk about it
that's an important thing it's time
um
more just kind of the like what if the
delay changed the seasons at all the
kind of knows like as you know our is
expansions our expansion is now going to
be November is anything shortened just
kind of to to know if that changed
anything and that may be like a fluid
thing but to know if like that delay
actually has changed anything officially
um
I want to have some more clarification
on sun setting
a lot of people are automatic like I see
so many people up in arms about Sunset
and angry about sun sign and it's like
the only content that you're not going
to be able to use these past weapons for
is light enabled which is raids which is
Gambit but Gamba doesn't really count
and raids trials
iron Banner on Gambit that is the only
light leveled enabled content in Destiny
2.
and I mean like endgame raid like the
new rage the rest of the rage doesn't
matter I want to know
um
how like are they actually going to be
implementing better guns or guns that we
are more likely to use right because how
do you top a Mountaintop how do you
revoker yeah annoys me
revoker annoys me so much
reward on headshots don't reward on
missed shots
there you go
be enough
um
or me of
the which game bit go and go
[__] Gambit gongo best we gotta know
cause I've I've come full circle I've I
was a I was a regular Gambit guy but
prime prime all day for me now I've
completely flipped the script me and
Paul Tassie together have seen the light
it's all about prime I would love that
and I would love the sets to come back
and I would like to yes yeah some kind
of evolution of the sets would be good
uh I know we're not getting armor 2.0 or
armor 3.0 or any evolution of armor they
flat set it because they said the
solstice arm is going to last which for
me is kind of sad but on the other side
maybe an evolution in the weapon
Department people are wondering if there
is a weapons 2.0 to some extent we know
stasis is coming with an element for
energy weapons and heavy weapons and
stuff like that alone and subclasses
which that's I guess another piece too I
want to understand how that subclass
works is it that custom tree that we
heard of is it gonna be a fourth one
like hat just a little Clarity or is it
just log in earn your quest and then see
it that day
yeah but yeah understanding if the
weapons are going to change the mods if
Exotics are going to have a mod slot on
them yep season mods on Exotics yeah
I want to know how vogue's going to be
affected
I want to know what is there gonna be
our favorite
is there going to be is there going to
be champions in the raid are they gonna
change how things work are they gonna
because if they're just copying and
pasting it straight from D1 and D2 all
the people that have run Vogue a million
times are gonna have an easy easy enough
time my other interest in that is that
the will be there will there be another
race for like world's first race it's
already been completed that's true you
know we had to complete it in D1 are
they if there's if they're gonna
publicize that as another world's first
race and they're gonna honor that or the
people who won Vogue world's first
and D1 are they going to feel cheated by
it good point
very interesting do they change
mechanics do they add stuff new do yeah
you know then you got the Purity people
who like oh don't touch that's gonna be
interesting that's a good point the way
they handle it that is a they're in a
bit of a touchy situation that's a very
emotional rate for people
oh for me uh transmog uh trans how is it
going to be handled the specifics you
know I would love a breakdown on that
that's going to be very interesting
we're excited about it but you know pure
implementation explanation how they're
doing you know handling the systems
would be cool
uh leveling
Oh I wanna know like I mean you said it
earlier too and it's one thing they've
kind of teased that they're trying to
get away from bounties what does that
mean is it the fact that if you run a
raid I'm like is that like worth a
level's worth on a season pass if you
finish a raid are you letting you finish
every encounter versus going to farm
bounties and stuff like that if you sit
in the strike playlist for two hours you
don't have to go back and pick up
bounties can I get bounties from space
which I think they mentioned at some
point yeah they mentioned yeah um what
is yeah just like the whole
leveling progression because making us
do all the powerfuls and the Pinnacles
and
I think I don't know if they're gonna
completely throw a wrench into that for
a full change but it is getting to feel
samey after especially seasonally now
because we do it every season yeah and
we know it's 50 per level because they
literally gave us the numbers of what
it's going to change right
hopefully some kind of evolution there
but leveling and bounties because they
mentioned they're getting away so tell
us what's changing
yep yep yep
if
no this may have already been covered so
please help me but I want to know
whether so the cosmodrome was coming
back and obviously Bob is coming back
they're being unvolid are they going to
be voltage when it comes to the witch
Queen are they gonna stay
because they're not as large as all of
the planets that we're getting rid of so
my question is are is this going to be
the star of
implementing all of D1 into D2 like a
lot of people have been calling for
it won it's a good one it's a good
question I was like what they I was like
to my remembering of what they said I
know each expansion is getting a new
planet so we get Europa which Queen gets
some more new and then lightfall gets
somewhere new but also on the other side
you get to add
like and I'm kind of with you I'm
wondering with witch Queen do we get
Dreadnought yes
that gives me dread notebook please
I think that'd be a nice way like if we
get saved and again they're taking four
planets out they said they're trying to
bring it down to a manageable level so
now we're gonna do that exchange so if I
don't think 80s ever edz really can ever
leave just because the tower's there I
don't think we ever get to completely
ditch EDC maybe we do maybe unless we
have the cosmodrome yeah it's basically
that basically takes over Earth so we
have them we have Earth yeah
yeah it's interesting yeah
but I was like so you might lose
something like nessus
I think Tangled Shore and dreaming City
will stay around through witch Queen
they have to I think because that all
ties together yeah yes so much of
Sabbath in story is amazing in the
shower Throne they have to keep that I
would be interested to see whether the
end of the witch Queen year yep they
Sunset though these Sunset those because
at the end of that year that's when we
solved the curse which means we still
have another two full years before we
solve the curse which I feel so sorry
yeah that's so crazy they need to I'm
sorry I'm gonna say this really quickly
Bungie needs to get better at linear
storytelling and actually linking it in
because I feel like there's too much
there's two like we're still getting
stories coming back
um
and we're still dealing with the cabal
three years later yes why are they still
here we have silently kicked their butts
and we have go all over here yeah Talus
is chilling as the Viking but apparently
he's a good guy why are we still dealing
with these guys three years later when
we have amazing
amazing
shout out to Aldrin yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's just it needs
there needs to be a bit more linked
instead of waiting three years to before
the end of a story yes it's confusing
and obviously Bungie are in a very very
difficult position especially with the
dreaming City zooming city is on a
constant as a as in a constant Loop
right if we can they need to then start
looking and instancing so if someone who
has completed has solved the curse when
they go to the gyming city it's entirely
different to someone who launches in
there and hasn't solved the curse I know
World of Warcraft did that really well
where like if there is someone that
hasn't done something particular it
hasn't completed a certain part of a
quest the area that they go to is
entirely different than someone going to
the same area but they have completed
that part of the quest they need to
start doing instancing to provide
more of a I don't even mean like
they don't just need to sit us down in a
chair and be like basically picture
booking this is how this story goes yeah
but what I mean is is that I could do
without two years between a bit of Story
and Another bit of story like connective
threads
as opposed to here's your story threads
they don't connect I know they're just
all here
I mean this is this is this podcast
right here in a
nutshelling dangling unanswered
questions that's this podcast yes
I'll make my last one this be my final
one um you know it I got the shirt
trials baby trials we need love besides
the anti-cheat what are you doing what
are you doing with these rewards what
are you doing with the guns what about
my Adept weapons what about you know
let's get to it let's let's let's fix it
up let's shape it up you know hopefully
that could be that nice combo package
with the anti-cheat and a nice coat of
paint don't know if it's gonna happen
Beyond light it may not but at least if
they talk about it it give us a road map
or be transparent as to what the
expectation of these things are going to
be then I am fine
yeah
final one put a boat
how many strikes do we get because we're
losing like
how many ounces I haven't even done the
math on the ones we're losing it's not
that hard but I was like we're losing
enough that we'll one two three four
five we're losing like half or seventy
percent yeah like six seven six seven
that's like six or seven strikes like
we're not getting we're not getting the
six or seven there's no way in hell I
would imagine that but I was like I
still want to know how many we get that
are not story missions from Europa oh
please spell no I can't deal with that
because these are your story missions
yeah as your strikes please for the love
of God I was like how many times have we
killed Zoll
long
we killed a worm God in a story Mission
then we had to do it all over again in a
strike and you're just like this makes
zero sense
rather resources they disrespected us
all so much
we just pull out regular guns get them
girl God you ain't nothing wrong
yeah he's dead before he comes up yes
yeah I mean I know we technically
carries all along and Whisper the worm
like I know basically he is the whisper
of the Worm but they basically just
reused Touch of malice with oryx it's
like
stop it just please
give these massive enemies that
apparently were supposed to fear the
respect they deserve
my only worry is that we have like it's
a fallen Kell but I'm like how big can a
fallen Kell no for Aramis though that's
like our boss in the fall and yeah she's
gonna have stasis Powers now maybe
stasis is like
made her something special but I was
like how big can a fallen Kell be and
why are you dying over there
[Music]
with a whisper still petting yourself
yeah
that's a beautiful way to end it I think
stop hitting yourself for the win
well I was like this has been a hell of
a lot of fun seriously
I was like we could probably ramble on
until things had to actually get done
but we should probably start tidying
things up just a little bit but yeah I'm
very curious to see where everything
goes in the fall and yeah but I mean
floor is completely yours
um it's been an absolute pleasure having
you on of course thanks for the honor on
the other side for joining the uh Royale
warm-up combo but I was like for you uh
it has been a pleasure having you around
the campfire
tell everybody where they can find you
what you got going what you do what
you're known for it's the Floor Source
it's all yours
[Laughter]
right now no pressure James does this to
me all the time hi I'm Ali I do uh PVE
content on twitch.tv forward slash
Rebecca I do a lot of teaching
um I teach people how to do raids I help
them do things that they can't do
without fire teams I'll take them
through whisper missions I'll take them
through
um oh what's the other one zero hours
and everything like that and we've been
doing a lot of night falls recently as
well the night falls are really fun I'm
actually I'm enjoying the grand Masters
a lot this week this season that I was
last
um
what I've got going on in exactly
and four and a half hours I'm going to
be doing a charity stream
for the Trevor Project no oh nice great
great program yeah I know about that so
uh that's gonna be fun that's gonna be
on the vision Farm channel uh it's all
put together by Activision by Jess she's
amazing
um that's what I've got going on I don't
um I'm known for a lot of
teaching and podcasting and whether I be
on podcasts or I run podcasts I am
I'm a rash in the destiny 2 Community
you just cannot get rid of me everywhere
there's a lot of jokes you can have in
there I'm gonna say oh yeah over here
oh that's hilarious no I was like
honestly you are a very very very
hard-working individual of the destiny
Community it just may not get as much
love and also to all of you out there go
follow her on Twitch for sure definitely
lurk on her stream help push her to
partner just to make sure that thing
goes through absolutely yes I do have
the app in it's just it's not um twitch
have taken their time getting back to me
which I'm fine with by the way twitch
just as long as you know at the end of
the six or seven week wait yes okay
don't make me wait like seven weeks and
tell me no yeah thank you rip the
Band-Aid off if you got bad news just
rip it off but you can wait as long as
you want for good news right yeah
absolutely yeah salute salute tremendous
stuff
Cognito yeah man well first of all game
before I get into my truck I guess Lou
Audi for coming through super super
positive does a lot of good things in
the community love the teaching aspect
love the helping you know putting people
to raise and then also the charity stuff
you know I caught our on the uh the
mental health with the filler I thought
that was really really positive really
dope and as well as a guardian Royale
with ebonics when I first you know came
across for Content stuff like that so
really cool very positive and helping
people so salute the audience get her to
partner he's getting that rocket out you
know like do do the needful
exactly so it's a little bit yeah y'all
know me man Lord Cognito on Twitter I
love podcast every Sunday 1 p.m Eastern
is the Lord's Day come check us out we
will have big cloud gaming on this week
we'll talk about all the latest video
game news so Halo infinix delayed uh
rumors of PlayStation 5 exclusive a lot
of console stuff and then uh I think
epic suing everybody about fortnite so
that'll be fun so come join us we'll
talk some uh some legal stuff as well as
some gaming and then also again
everybody salute thank you guys for
supporting on launchinggaming.net we're
really doing well with the Articles you
guys are really tweeting that and
sharing that stuff we get a lot of
positive stuff and of course my brother
King David if you're into statues Marvel
DC all that stuff he's got an amazing
Thanos up right now so check that out
king of the statues it's on IMO podcast
and of course I ain't gonna say because
he hate what I said you know the support
the last word we love we love you guys
in the chat every week we see it grow
and you see a little bit more and a
little bit more and uh we really
appreciate the positive thoughts and
Vibes you guys give us and the laughs
and the jokes and stop trying to make me
an e-fight that's the other thing stop
that I see what you'll be doing
sometimes but anyway
I mean they're like hashtag best banter
but you know that's totally fine they
threw that one out there but yes even
you Crystal even you yeah he just
literally wants to just text me he's
ready today I'm so watch the world burn
yeah pretty much uh so you guys know me
uh grinding this stuff out maybe
Avengers beta want to get to act three
of ghost of sushima but uh YouTube you
guys have been fantastic lately I'm like
less than 200 Subs away from 50k
yeah it's like less than it's a hunt
it's 49 872 right now so hopefully next
week I can walk in with some awesome
news
um
it's like a round number that can
finally be like I have 47 and I have no
it's like it's
have a big round number that's like
halfway to 100 so it's like you like and
honestly what
close baby let's get it I was like it's
you guys have been crazy the support on
the couple guides for Solstice have been
awesome so YouTube Twitter twitch all
the places you can find me if it's
ebontist and the cheetah it's me so if
you trip over that you found the right
place and yeah we're gonna go raid Obi
Katie cat this morning because I know
she is uh streaming right now so I'm
gonna send you guys over there in a
second but we gotta wrap this thing up
so you guys have been awesome this
morning an amazing guest a professional
just I'm gonna say it again one more
time a badass as well Addie thank you
very much for joining us this morning it
has been an ultra pleasure
it's been my pleasure seriously it's
been really good to chill with you guys
yeah so for episode 116 August 14th
thank you guys very much it has been